I'm going to onboard program a 2014 Ford
Mustang
you
if you have two working keys that start
the car you can add a third or fourth
key no problem at all so just watch the
process here we're gonna do an onboard
programming as long as you have two
working keys also they have to be
original keys they can't be a clone if
they're a clone you may have two working
keys if it's a clone it's not going to
add the third key so it has to be to
what we call master keys and then you
can add a third or fourth key so this is
the process here there's no ten-minute
wait time it's just pretty simple two
working keys program the third try it
and you'll see I'm gonna onboard program
the 2014 Ford Mustang you have to have
two master keys that will start the car
so the two keys that will start the car
already to add in a third key so we're
gonna onboard program this is a super
chip this is custom made and I should be
able to onboard program this third key
and a fourth key and a fifth key
whatever I want so I have two functional
master keys now they cannot be a clone
if one of these is a clone you cannot do
onboard programming with a clone
so you have to have two master keys that
both start the car so it's three to five
seconds so we're going to do this and
put in key number one one two three four
put it in the second key one two three
four
throw in the fifth key the third key
perfect so now all three keys and we can
even test the other two keys just to
make sure still perfect
and that is onward programming I hope
you enjoyed watching this video
subscribe to my channel also visit my
website and you can see what online
locksmith training I have for beginners
intermediate and advanced as well as my
covert methods of entry and my
non-destructive methods of entry
you
[Music]